bonjour à tous les samsung galaxy à 8 et
8 plus sont arrivées plus vite que prévu
on les attendait emballement pour une
annonce aux crs en janvier de l'année
prochaine samsung a coupé un peu la
foule puis à tout le monde d'ailleurs le
csj serait une prise en main dont je
vous invite à vous abonner pour tout
savoir sur ce produit et même d'ailleurs
plein d'autres choses parce que il y
aura plein de nouveautés samsung a coupé
l'herbe sous le pied à tout le monde a
annoncé ce produit directement sur son
site internet donc ce qu'on va faire
c'est que je vais vous le présenter tout
ça en trois minutes dans trois minutes
tech
[Musique]
samsung a pris tout le monde de court en
annonçant directement se produit sur son
site internet c'est vrai que vous avez
déjà fait une vidéo il ya quelques temps
d'ailleurs je vous invite à aller à la
voir des dans cette vidéo je vous
présentais les caractéristiques
techniques de ce que devait peut-être
ces samsung galaxy à 8 et a8 plus pour
le coup je me suis pas trompé alors
forcément les infos c'est pas moi qui
les ai inventées il ya eu beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de rumeurs sur
internet d'ailleurs j'ai une question à
vous poser toutes ces rumeurs est ce que
vous pensez qu elles sont directement
hors crise orchestrées par don par les
grandes marques comme samsung comme
apple ou comme autres ou alors est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est vraiment des
gens qui travaillent pour eux qu'ils les
sortent régulièrement pour donner des
informations et puis des infos un peu
croustillantes en avant première
mettez-moi en commentaire et plus on va
en discuter ensemble pour faire court je
vous présenter ces deux nouveaux
produits en seulement trois minutes on
leur compteur ce sont les successeurs
des samsung galaxy à 5000 seront
forcément moins cher qu'un samsung
galaxy s 9 qui sortira bientôt parce
qu'on n'est pas dans le haut de gamme on
est dans un milieu bien mais par contre
pas pu techniquement ils sont hyper sexy
à commencer par son grand écran infiniti
display fhd plus en 1080 par 2000 220
pixels un écran super amoled horatio de
18 points 5/9 avec une diagonale de 5,6
pour son galaxy à 8 et 6 pouces pour le
galaxy à 8 plus on devrait avoir une
vraie sensation diversion alors pas du
bord à bord comme sur les modèles haut
de gamme les ss8 et suit plus et bientôt
s 9 et s9 plus mais ça devrait vraiment
être super sexy et regarder les photos
c'est vrai que c'est un modèle qui est
très esthétique côté photo on a un vrai
paquet fait en avant par samsung sur sa
gamme à on a un double capteur à l'avant
un 16 mégapixels et un 8 mégapixels avec
une ouverture pour chacun en 1.9 vous
allez pouvoir choisir sur quel capteur
vous souhaitez shooter pour avoir je
dirais des selphy différents vous avez
un vrai mode portrait vous allez pouvoir
régler avant de faire la photo mais
également après avoir fait la photo et
il ya aussi plein de nouveautés qui sont
arrivés sur c'est sur ces différents
appareils photo vous allez pouvoir
ajouter des émoticônes des petites
images pas voir et pas mal de trucs
c'est ce très très sympa à l'arrière on
trouve une caméra 16 mégapixels avec un
objectif qui ouvre en en point c'est
donc on va très bien que samsung a fait
un bond déjà a compris que les sels
fille et bien c'était aujourd'hui ce que
les personnes faisait le plus on passe
plus de temps à se prendre en photo avec
nos amis à se mettre en scène pour
partager sur les réseaux sociaux tout
cas de faire des photos un peu plus
classique avec son appareil une grande
ouverture beaucoup de luminosité et sa
également normalement lorsque vous
n'aurez pas beaucoup de lumière côté
vidéo on aura de la stabilisation
numérique pour pouvoir effectivement
d'éviter les petits tremblements
lorsqu'on va faire des vidéos on aura
aussi également une option pour avoir
des time lapse donc des choses hyper
cool alors effectivement c'est à 8 et a8
plus seront pas aussi puissant que la
gamme s est sud est sud plus et s 9 s9
plus mais ils devraient tirer leur
épingle du jeu côté processeur il y à un
acte accord 2,2 giga hertz duale et 1,6
gigahertz exact on devrait peut-être
retrouver un exil aux 7885 à l'intérieur
au niveau de la mémoire vive on va
retrouver sur le à 8 4 gigas drapée sur
le à 8 plus soit 4 gigas de ram soit 6
giga de ram ça ça va dépendre un petit
peu des pays dans lequel ils sont
distribués j'espère que sur 1 à 8 plus
on aura quand même du sis giga de ram
côté stockage les deux modèles seront
proposés en 32es en 64 giga qu'on pourra
monter bien évidemment en 256 go grâce à
une carte micro sd il devrait tenir le
choc avec une batterie pour le a8 de
3000 milliards erreur et une batterie
pour le a8 plus de 3500 milliampères
heures n'étonneront tous les deux sous
android 7 points un point 1-1 nous gave
pour l'instant on n'a pas d'info quant à
une mise à jour sur android 8.0 oreo ils
ont de l'usbc du bluetooth 5.0 je
regrette moi par contre que le capteur
d'empreintes digitales soit classé en
dessous de l'appareil photo chose qui
fait peur ce que vous allez chercher à
déverrouiller votre appareil si vous ne
connaissez pas encore bien ne l'est pas
encore bien en main vous aussi posez vos
doigts sur l'appareil photo est
forcément john's à lire un petit peu le
l'objectif ça c'est un peu le point de
revoir point positif vous avez une
certification ip68 ce qui fait que si
vous tombez dans la cuvette des
toilettes chez vous il peut être immergé
jusqu'à 1 mètre 50 pendant 30 minutes à
l'eau douce attention à tout ce qui va
être au salé ou eau chlorée houle
affectivement la garantie pourrait
sauter et surtout ce qui est super
intéressant un super sexy c'est que ce
samsung galaxy à 8 et a8 plus seront les
premiers modèles à être compatible avec
le casque de réalité virtuelle de
samsung ça c'est génial là vers on y va
de plus en plus on va beaucoup appareils
dans les temps à venir mais ça c'est un
vrai pas en avant dans les produits de
milieu de gamme de chez samsung
d'ailleurs on a vu que samsung a sorti
cette année une nouvelle version de son
casque nouvelle version de sa caméra et
forcément il faut que les appareils
compatibles pour pouvoir vendre ses
produits et ça c'est un vrai plus alors
c'est un produit qui sera disponible en
noir gris or et bleu pour l'instant on
ne sait pas quelles couleurs seront
disponibles en france on pourra
l'acheter à partir du mois de janvier
2018 on connais pas encore le tarif mais
on peut imaginer un tarif pour le a8 à
499 et pour le a8 plus à 599 pour moi
c'est samsung galaxy à 8 à 8 plus ce
sont les concurrents directs du one + 5
t et d'autres modèles qui vont arriver
notamment le honorio 10 et tous les
modèles moyenne gamme ça marchait qui
est plus concurrentiel donc samsung doit
vraiment être en place là avec ces deux
modèles il frappe vraiment un coup fort
notamment avec le double capteur photo à
l'avant cela pour moi c'est essentiel
tout voilà ce qu'on peut dire en 3,65
galaxie à 8 et a8 plus dites moi vous ce
que vous en pensez est ce que ces
modèles pourraient vous intéresser
qu'est ce que vous préférez le one + 5 t
entre les grande famille dans lequel
votre coeur balance mettez moi tout ça
en commentaire je vous invite à vous
abonner pas ce qu'on fera une prise en
main quand je serai à las vegas au cs on
va parler de plein d'autres produits on
va tester plein d'autres produits doha
plein de nouveautés une exclusivité donc
restez connectés je vous remercie
d'abord regarder cette vidéo je vous
invite à laisser des jolies pouces soyez
sages et je vous dis à très bientôt
tiens
[Musique]